tarzan's dad decides to wait until the
ship is entirely engulfed in flames and
has tilted basically 90 degrees to
abandon ship the point of no return was
a good 15 minutes ago dad this happy
family song almost makes me forget that
50 or more Souls surely just died in
that fiery ship drowning oh well I feel
Bobby goddamn have you ever seen a movie
that opened with five minutes a
narration in song cipher blame is of
course I love how these two crash-landed
here and are instantly liked well better
build a killer treehouse instead of like
well better build a killer signal fire
priorities man
what does Disney have against Wildcats
save over Shere Khan Tigger walked we
need to poo again you'll see what I mean
this is sad and all but it seems to be a
result of poor planning on the gorillas
park they couldn't have someone keeping
watch or something fucking jungle
it's a leopard eat baby gorilla world
out there movie made me do research on
gorillas hearing abilities
newsflash they're not as good as ours so
there was no fucking way she could hear
a baby crying halfway across the jungle
okay so if I understand the movie
correctly she literally just lost her
child then she went on a wild rampage
looking for the source of this non
gorilla child screaming noise and now
she's gonna adopt this kid even though
we never saw his parents die or even
face adversity do I have that right
because if so this movie
Tarzan's parents sure have a lot of even
though their entire ship burned and sank
does this movie really expect me to
believe that all these linens feather
pillows books clocks armoires rope hats
frames and so on just washed up on the
beach so they could build this big
mansion in the trees it's super
convenient for the story that sable were
killed only cause baby and Tarzan's
parents how long have Tarzan and his
parents been here probably would have
taken them at least a few months to get
their house ready and maybe a few more
months for the vines to grow around
their house yet baby Tarzan looks like
he hasn't grown a fucking day since they
were shipwrecked this kid should be
bigger and walking around right kala
forgot she was a gorilla an animal that
is comfortable enough with poop to put
it in its hands and throw it there was
no reason for her to be disgusted by a
baby's diaper if anything she should
remove the diaper because she doesn't
understand its purpose I'm no expert but
I imagine a gorilla would mostly own a
leopard in a fight please discuss the
scenario further in the comments
I'm starting to think baby Tarzan is
incapable of crying I don't care how
tough this kid is a leopard gorilla
fight would scare the out of any baby
this net is here because when Tarzan's
parents we're building the place they
thought we should put a net here because
if we're ever killed and our baby gets
rescued by a gorilla we don't want our
baby falling to his death when said
gorilla is fighting the leopard that
killed us a little bit sidetracked
[Music]
that's even more racist comma it won't
replace the one we lost as a husband let
me just say this asshole has no idea how
to husband was it alone interestingly in
real life Silverbacks have multiple
mates though this movie will attempt to
make you think this one male is bonded
to this one female in monogamy I said he
could stay that doesn't make him my son
dad I'm going to call him Tarzan roll
credits but please do so in a Phil
Collins song please I applaud her
efforts to save and raise this obviously
non gorilla baby but what's she gonna do
when that diaper gets full she even know
how to make new diapers does she have an
Amazon Prime account set up to ship
diapers every month
I mean she's buried in poop in three
days no and what should turn into a
hilarious farce about an ape changing
diapers and wrangling up juice boxes for
this asshole kid instead just jumps
ahead ears like there were no issues and
Tarzan is now a badass without any
learning curve whatsoever it's good
Tarzan's parents are dead because they
just want to build a house in that tree
ah sugar gliders wait sugar gliders
don't have evil RIT glow-in-the-dark
eyes they're actually lovable and
awesome do you movie Tarzan raised my
animals almost his whole life still
needs a modesty loincloth mostly by
aging so many years overnight a leopard
killed your parents and you don't know
it oh man Rosie O'Donnell dragged the
movie into this didn't she proof my
brother descended from apes
[Music]
Tarzan survives this
Tarzan learns how to swim after watching
a hippo swim for two seconds based on
this film and the Jungle Book Disney
clearly thinks that all elephant herds
have only one young male it would
explain why they're endangered
the study of bacteria reached a
civilization untouched by man this
asshole elephant kid knows what piranhas
are or at least thinks he does there are
no piranhas in Africa how does he even
know their name then of course the
wrapper is right there native to South
America how do any of you know any of
these elephants in the early 1900s kala
look at him he will never be one of us
the silverback is both racist and
correct you will get a waterfall and you
get a waterfall and you how in the fuck
did this jungle raise man-cub child
managed to see the movie predator wait a
second I've been nervous all video about
how to refer to these primates apes
gorillas monkeys etc and I assumed by
the inclusion of a silverback alpha male
this movie was telling me they were
gorillas but this kid casually calls
them all Apes basically and the movie
does not object so at a minimum I should
be given free rein in this sense video
to call them whatever the hell monkey
name I choose to call it right how many
bananas did these assholes have piled up
and ready to eat
Jesus they go bad you know this Gator
situation is way more deadly than
anything Tarzan faces in this entire
movie but because it's part of a happy
montage it's treated as a playful game
whatever Tarzan's dead yo this ain't
pitfall hilarious moment of nearly
killing the silverback it's like this
movie takes the totally believable
premise of Apes raising a human and then
shits all over the realness of it with
crap like this Tarzan is addictive
animals basically and Disney animation
loves aging a character up through song
and visual transition I don't care how
awesome a pharaoh man beast you are that
waterfall would knock him on his ass
tree surfing the high-end lifespan of a
leopard is 17 years there's no way
Tarzan is only 17 years old it's a shame
that Apes arbitrarily cannot talk to the
leopard like they can talk to other
species if they could they may be able
to work something out
was amazed I swear no one will be seated
during the FERC joke portion of the
movie he's humans who we later see or a
rather small party are causing big herd
of elephant type rumbling in the trees I
get that this takes place a long time
ago but it still seems weird to me that
Jane would wear her bell dress on a hike
through the woods this guy is a super
discount Gaston considering that he's
shooting mostly blind that was a damn
good shot if Tarzan wasn't made of
rubber this movie would be over now
what do you think no one in the goddamn
world can draw monkeys that quickly just
study gorillas lady if you think that
thing was a baboon you have no business
research and gorillas one of his people
on the count of three Jane assumes this
baboon knows how to count to three
I'd read us in about the spinning bull
but I threw up during it so that's the
sin this works somehow cartoon character
gradually floats down to the ground by
way of umbrella cliche Disney timing
well clearly he's just listening for her
heartbeat but still I think ear to
breast contact is typically something
that occurs in a third date I mean my
experience it was a 16th date but I'm
pretty sure I'm an outlier very nice
very nice this is the equivalent of me
hearing one sentence in Mandarin one
time and then repeating it back
perfectly did Tarzan just perfectly
mimic the sound of a gunshot he's the
Michael Winslow of the jungle this is a
party of three people one of whom went
missing with Tarzan so two people set
all this up after the female of the
group went missing who takes a goddamn
grandfather clock on an overseas voyage
to study gorillas hilarious Beauty and
the Beast nod is hilarious thanks for
adding to the runtime of this movie
previous spider movie I left at least
three human years took the time to start
some red liquid dripping chemistry
experiments before they left to explore
the jungle Turk would rule with
cinemasins
[Music]
physics blowing through a gramophone
horn will not sound like a muted trumpet
people mostly just sound like normal
blow it this song is actually pure
gibberish Bravo Disney Bravo it's the
want to be like you for a new generation
instead of finger pants this gala merely
falls down which is sinful as does
anyone in that position in real life
with their pants case closed
do not let them see you and do not seek
them out they mean us no harm feel like
the movie is trying to paint Kerchak as
the judgemental bad guy in the situation
but he couldn't be more right Tarzan I
don't know that I do I've spent time
with them you really haven't you've
briefly spent time with one of them and
she just happens to be the young woman
who was really hot and on top of that
you've never seen a human woman before
so your judgment is severely impaired is
the animation in the late 90s I love
them some giant forearms wow this super
daughter who rules at science and
intelligence is also an amazing artist
she should work for Disney I focused on
the blackboard okay first of all she's a
lady and does not discuss her
masturbation habits with anyone second
of all how the fuck do you think she's
gonna get off with a fucking chalkboard
third of all are you not her father
shouldn't you be jailed for even making
this comment fourth and finally what the
fuck Disney Cars and should not be
fascinated by a mustache
Tarzan should have a full beard if I can
teach a parrot to sing god save the
queen
I can certainly teach this savage Athena
- that is a fallacy of logic one thing
has nothing to do with the other also
I'd like some proof on that parrot god
save the queen claim before moving any
further forward because I think you're
much too vain to ever lower yourself and
I fast to teach a parrot overuse of
montages okay we're headed to the
African jungle in search of Apes let's
definitely remember to pack the entire
history of mankind on film just in case
we bump into any man ape hybrids along
the way we've taken nearly an hour to
get here let's go super speed through
Tarzan's humana fication
wait it's bad enough they brought a so
trope of this bicycle they actually
brought an actual life-sized version of
it and he's supposed to be riding it
along mossy tree branches you know what
do you movie i'm stickier you contain a
lot of Tarzan's boner control is on
point or I guess in this instance it's
not on point do you understand I
understand you learned their language
and what I mean how many weeks of
provisions could they possibly have
this expedition 3 these Forrest Gump
meets Travolta from phenomenon times
data from Star Trek Jesus this movie
should come with a warning for people
with epilepsy this guy way over Poor's
these wineglasses what the hell am I
doing with my life it's only important
to Tarzan that Jane stays right so why
did he have to bring the professor and
Clayton long better yet why didn't he
just convinced her to go up with him to
the camp so Jane could see a gorilla
instead of bringing them all back to the
habitat
[Music]
science fainting oh such a two years why
does every Disney character caught
waking up and half dreaming always seem
to have sex on the brain
the professor's pockets must have the
same powers as Mary Poppins back perhaps
that's an English thing well he thinks
any kind of human could subdue and hold
back a silverback gorilla movie is
stupid ah the old Disney I've done
something bad so now I must run a weekly
shit
we really should hand it to Tarzan's
senior for building this place he built
a house out of water damage charred
pieces of wood that stayed structurally
sound for over 20 years
also Tarzan has been able to run all
over the jungle his entire life and
never once found this treehouse
loincloth upgrade big gorillas don't cry
because gorillas actually physically
cannot cry Tarzan did a great job of
figuring out cufflinks for someone who's
never worn clothes before this could
almost be the end of the movie where
Tarzan realizes he's human and joins the
other humans and I could make an
argument that maybe it should be but
honestly I'm kind of tired
nope cue movie you nut asshole dickweed
so he wants me to believe that a tower
using his elephant hooves climbed up
that chain and onto this ship
[Music]
we're Tarzan do you yell so they know to
look for you taking them by surprise
will be too easy Tarzan saw paranormal
activity forget man not understanding
that you have OS Ben this is a total
bullshit change of heart Kerchak was
right to distrust the humans the
majority of humans they've encountered
tried to kidnap and kill them if
anything he should distrust them even
more Jane yeah I can't help feeling that
you should stay it's every Victorian
father's dream to leave his daughter
behind in the jungles so she can
Canadian and probably die of disease or
travel birth within the year I don't
care how much you love someone you
should always love civilization more
[Music]
my baby don't cry when you try and find
him well but when you finish
registration down little bit scared
while on there are so many songs about
rainbows
[Music]
we've chosen not only to believe in
ourselves but in each other
today there's not a man nor woman in
here that shall stand alone
with an exhilarating
apes follow go by now but we shall be
your friend get this movable feast
underway